سنبدا بالتطورات الميدانيه في اوكرانيا
حيث ذوه صباح اليوم اذا انفجارات في
العاصمه كيف بينما فادت السلطات بوقوع
ضربه صاروخيه روسيه جديده اقلت الرئاسه
الاوكرانيه انه تم تفعيل عمل المضادات
الجويه في سمائك كما تم تفعيله عمل
المضادات في مناطق عده من بينها مقاطعه
اوديسا جنوبيه هذا كتب المستشار الرئاسي
على صفحته في فيسبوك انا اكثر من 100
صاروخ انطلقت فيه موجات عده وانه يمكن
سماع وصفات الانذار من الغارات في جميع
انحاء
وهذه الصور اذا وصلتنا قبل قليل من
العاصمه
الاوكرانيه
هذه اخر الصور اذا التي تصل من اكياف اذا
كما قلنا دوه هذا الصباح انفجارات هناك
وقد افادت السلطات بوقوع ضربه صاروخيه
روسيه جديده
الصباح متفاصل
بالفعل سفيان العاصمه الاوكرانيه منذ
ساعات صباح الاولى وهي تحت الانذار تحت
حاله التاهب الجوي بالاضافه الى كل
المقاطعات
التصريحات تصل تباعا عن المسؤولين هنا في
كياب والادارات العسكريه في مقاطعات
الجنوب على وجه التحديد
والحديث بالفعل عن تجدد الهجمات الروسيه
الحديث عن نحو مئه صاروخ انطلقت بالفعل
100 صاروخ روسي والحديث
مواصفات الاوكرانيه خلال الدقائق الماضيه
ل- الطيران الاستراتيجي الروسي فوق البحر
الاسود الدفاعات الجويه بالفعل تعمل في
هذه الاثناء في العاصمه في منطقه كيا في
ضواحي كياب همم هي ربما يعني همم تفسر
الانفجارات او اصوات الانفجارات التي صنعت
خلال نصف ساعه الاخيره الدقائق الاخيره
عمده يتجدد القصف الان الان سفيان القصف
في قلب او او لاكون دقيق اكثر ال ال ال
مضادات المضادات الجويه الاوكرانيه الان
في قلب المدينه تتجدد مره اخرى المضادات
الجويه الاوكرانيه ثلاثه اصوات ثلاثه
اصوات في هذه اللحظه في المحيط الذي نقف
في نحن نقف الان في ميدان الاستقلال هذا
الميدان الرئيسي والمضادات تعمل
بالقرب من منطقه القصر الرئاسي اليس كذلك
نعم
استمع الى صوت المضادات في المنطقه التي
يوجد فيها القصر الرئاسي في قلب العاصمه
كياب استطيع القول باننا نستمع الان او
استمعنا قبل قليل ونحن نتحدث الى اربع
انفجار همم اربع اصوات اربع اصوات لمضادات
جويه عندك كيف قال بالفعل بان المضادات
الجويه تعمل الان في العاصمه وفي ضواحي
العاصمه ودعا السكان الى الاتحاد الاماكن
همم الامنه والى البقاء في الملاجئ وهذه
المضادات الجويه استطيع القول بانها تعمل
الان في عموم مقاطعات البلاد لاسيما
المقاطعات الجنوبيه تحديدا في مقاطعه
اوديسا في مقاطعه ميكو لايف وفي المقاطعات
الشماليه وانا انتظر هذا الهواء كان عمده
ميكولاج يقول بان الدفاعات الجويه
الاوكرانيه اسقطت بالفعل اربع صواريخ اربع
صواريخ روسيه كانت تستهدف المدينه هذا ما
صدر عن همم عمده مقاطعه ميكو لايف ودعاء
السكان الى البقاء في الملاجئ الشركه
الوطنيه للكهرباء شركه الاوكرانيه
بالتاكيد همم دعت قالت بانها تنفذ قطع ما
سمته بقطع طارئ للتيار الكهربائي في
مقاطعه قدسها في مقاطعه حتى هنا في
المقاطعه في اماكن واسعه من العاصمه هنالك
قطع للتيار الكهربائي وقالت الشركه بان
هذا القطع هو قطع اضطراري الهدف منه
التعامل مع اي اضرار محتمله قد تنتج عن
القصف الروسي اذن التطورات على الميدان
متسارعه متلاحقه السلطات تتحدث بالفعل عن
هجمه جديده للقوات الروسيه وتقول بان هذا
الهجوم هو هجوم واسع انطاق عمده كياف
ومستشار الرئيس الاوكراني ايضا احد
مستشاري الرئيس الاوكراني كان يتحدث خلال
الدقائق الاخيره عن اكثر من 100 صاروخ
روسي بالفعل وهذه الصواريخ واضح بانها
تستهدف مقاطعات واسعه همم اماكن واسعه هذه
الهجمات تاتي في ظل اشتداد المعارك بين
القوات الاخرانيه والروسيه على اكثر من
جبهه على ارضي اكثر من مقاطعه
يعني ماذا عن توقيت يعني هذه الهجمات وهذا
القصف في
هناك حديث من الجانبين الروسي والاكرانيا
عن مفاوضات وحوارنا الى ذلك
بالفعل الاهميه سفيان لانه ياتي في ظل
تصعيد لغه الخطاب بين الجانب الروسي
والاكراني سياسيا دبلوماسيه الحديث لا
يهدا هنا في العاصمه كييف على لسان كبار
القاده السياسيين والعسكريين بانه لن تكون
هنالك اي مفاوضات مباشره بين كياف وروسيا
الا بالمقاس الاوكراني الا بالشروط
الاوكرانيه طيله الايام الماضيه كانت
السلطات الاوكرانيه تحديدا الرئيس
الاوكراني الذي كان يتحدث مساء امس في
البرلمان الاوكراني بانه لن يكون هنالك
مفاوضات ولن يتم الجلوس على طاوله الحوار
ولن يتم التوصل الى اي سلام محتمل بين
روسيا واوكرانيا الا بالشروط الاوكرانيه
والشروط الاوكرانيه ذهبت الى ابعد من ذلك
همم ولم تطالب فقط بانسحاب القوات
الاوكرانيه من مناطق الدنباش وما تبقى من
مواقع تتواجد فيها القوات الروسيه في
زبرجه في خرسان جنوب البلاد وانما ذهبت
الى ابعد من ذلك بمطالبه الجانب الروسي
بالانسحاب من شبه جزيره القرم الرئيس
الاوكراني قال بشكل واضح يوم امس
بان القوات الاوكرانيه ستعمل على اعاده
الحياه الى شبه جزيره القرم كما وصف
ومناطق الدنباش وذهب الى ابعد من ذلك في
الحقيقه سفيان عندما قال بان العام المقبل
هو عام النصر وان على القوات الاوكرانيه
ان تكثف جهودها في الميدان وقال بانه
سيعمل
باقصى ما يمكن بكل قدراته لتسريع
المساعدات العسكريه الغربيه
الامريكيه التي قال بانها بدات بالفعل
تغير من شكل المعادله على الارض وانها سوف
تغير كثيرا خلال الفتره المقبله وتحدثها
بالتاكيد عن ان السنه الجديده سوف تكون
سنه حاسمه وقلبي انها ستكون لصالح الجيش
الاوكراني لغه الخطاب في الحقيقه
سياسيه هنا في كيب خلال ال- ال- اربعه
خمسه ايام الماضيه بدات تتصاعد بشكل كبير
هنالك تاكيد من قبل الرئيس الاوكراني من
قبل مستشار الرئيس الاوكراني من قبل
الوزاره الخارجيه الاوكرانيه من قبل وزاره
الدفاع الاوكرانيه بان ال ال الكفه تتغير
في عديد المناطق وبان القوات الاوكرانيه
تمسك بزمام الامور في اكثر من جبهه في
اكثر من مقاطعه